>> Greg: PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT DRAMA
PUTTING THE WHITE HOUSE AND
MEDIA IN A TOUGH SPOT.
ANOTHER BRUTAL DAY IN THE
BRIEFING ROOM FOR THE PRESS
SECRETARY, KARINE JEAN-PIERRE,
WHO REFUSES TO ANSWER SIMPLE
QUESTIONS.
>> WHY SHOULDN'T AMERICANS BE
UPSET ABOUT DOCUMENTS FOUND IN A
GARAGE?
>> THAT'S FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO DECIDE.
THE PRESIDENT GOES OUT AND TALKS
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ALSO CARE ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
>> ON FRIDAY, DID YOU OR DID YOU
NOT KNOW ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTS?
>> I LITERALLY JUST ANSWERED
THAT QUESTION.
>> BUT YOU ADMIT THAT
YESTERDAY --
>> YOU'RE NOT TOO FAR SITTING
NEXT TO HER, SO I WAS VERY
CLEAR.
I PROVIDED -- I PROVIDED THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU ALL HAD AT
THE TIME.
YOU CAN ASK ME THIS 100 TIMES,
200 TIMES, IF YOU WISH.
I'M GOING TO KEEP SAYING THE
SAME THING.
I HEAR YOUR QUESTION.
IT'S BEEN ASKED.
IT'S BEEN ANSWERED.
IT'S BEEN NOTED.
>> Brian: WHILE SOME DEMOCRATS
AND PUNDITS HAVE BEEN HARSH,
OTHERS ARE MAKING NEW EXCUSES.
>> CAN'T HELP THEM MAKE FOOLS OF
THEMSELVES.
IT WHAT HAPPENED IN WHITEWATER,
THE EMAIL SCANDAL, AND THIS
HAPPENED NOW.
>> REPORTING SOMETIMES IS A
LITTLE MORE SENSATIONAL THAN IT
OUGHT TO BE.
I USED TO BE IN THE BUSINESS.
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY WE CAN
DO A WHOLE MEDIA SEGMENT ON THE
IDEA OF TRYING TO BE AGGRESSIVE
WHEN IT'S A DEMOCRAT TO BALANCE
OUT WHEN PEOPLE FEEL THAT
IT'S -- HE ACTUALLY DID THE
THINGS.
>> Jeanine: WOW.
>> Brian: BREAKING NEWS FROM THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
JUST INTO ALL OF US, THE DOJ HAS
CONSIDERED, BUT DECIDED AGAINST,
HAVING FBI AGENTS MONITOR A
SEARCH BY PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
LAWYERS FOR CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
AT HIS HOME, WHICH IS ONE
QUESTION YOU HAD.
WHY DO THEY GET TO SEARCH
THEMSELVES AND HAND OVER THIS
STUFF?
JUDGE, YOU WERE COMMENTING
DURING THIS WHOLE TIME.
FIRST OF ALL, ON THE REVELATION
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL" JUST
HAS, THAT THE FBI NIXED AND --
>> Jeanine: YOU JUST ASKED THE
QUESTION.
WHY DO THEY GET TO SEARCH THEIR
OWN RECORDS, CLASSIFIED RECORDS,
WITH PRIVATE LAWYERS WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT SECURITY
CLEARANCE?
BECAUSE THEY'RE DEMOCRATS.
THE HILLARY CLINTON CAN ERASE
33,000 EMAILS.
JOE BIDEN CAN MOVE THEM AROUND.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM WITH THESE
PEOPLE WHO SAY WE DON'T GET IT.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU'RE DEALING
WITH A GUY WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED
IN SUCKING UP MONEY FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD, LIVING WITH HIS
FATHER IN THE HOUSE WHERE THESE
DOCUMENTS ARE LOCATED, AND
NOBODY'S CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
OH, IT'S NOTHING TO SEE HERE,
FOLKS.
THEN YOU'VE GOT A PRESS PERSON
WHO LITERALLY IS STANDING AT THE
PODIUM SAYING, I ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION.
WELL, I DIDN'T HEAR IT.
WHAT DID YOU SAY?
YES OR NO?
ASK THE PERSON NEXT TO YOU.
SHE GOES ON FOR FIVE MINUTES
SAYING SHE ANSWERED IT, BUT SHE
WON'T ANSWER IT.
THIS IS THE TWILIGHT ZONE.
THERE'S NO WAY THAT JOE BIDEN,
WHO HAS RECORDS THAT ARE AT
LEAST SIX YEARS OLD, THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS OR DECLASSIFY HIMSELF.
NOW WE'VE GOT LAWYERS WITHOUT A
SECURITY CLEARANCE WHO WILL
INVARIABLY BE CALLED AS
WITNESSES.
IT'S GOING NOWHERE.
>> Geraldo: YOU'RE BURYING THE
LEAD.
THE LEAD IS THAT THEY DID ASK
THE DOJ WHETHER OR NOT THEY
SHOULD HAVE FBI AGENTS ACCOMPANY
THE PRIVATE LAWYERS.
>> Jeanine: WHO ASKED THE DOJ?
>> Geraldo: SOMEBODY DID.
THE DOJ APPARENTLY KNEW THAT THE
PRIVATE LAWYERS WERE SEARCHING.
I THINK IT'S ON MERRICK GARLAND.
WHAT IS MERRICK GARLAND?
>> Jeanine: THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
>> Geraldo: YOU HAVE THE BUDDING
SUSPICION THAT MERRICK GARLAND
IS REALLY PARTISAN.
I HATE TO COME TO THAT
CONCLUSION.
BUT IF HE PONDERED WHETHER FBI
AGENTS SHOULD HAVE ACCOMPANY THE
PRIVATE LAWYERS AND THEN SAID,
OH, NO, YOU GUYS DO IT, THAT TO
ME IS ON MERRICK GARLAND, NOT ON
JOE BIDEN.
>> Brian: DANA, THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME OUT ON THE
OFFENSIVE.
THEY SAID, LET'S GET THEM ON
THEIR HEELS BY SAYING, HEY, WHY
ARE YOU SO MAD AT US?
WHY DID THE REPUBLICANS COME
CLEAN ON THE DEAL
BEHIND-CLOSED-DOORS TO GIVE
KEVIN McCARTHY THE
SPEAKERSHIP?
WHAT KIND OF DEFENSE IS THAT?
>> Dana: YOU GOT TO ADMIRE
THEY'RE TRYING.
>> Brian: RIGHT.
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN'T BE SURE
HOW MANY DOCUMENTS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN HANDED OVER.
ONCE THEY HANDED OVER, THEY GOT
CONFUSED.
>> Dana: AND HOT POTATOES, I
DON'T WANT TO TOUCH IT, BECAUSE
THEY KNEW IT WAS WRONG.
YOU KNOW, THE WHOLE DRIP, DRIP,
DRIP THING, WORSE THAN
WATERGATE, HERE IT COMES.
THEY WOULD LOVE FOR THIS TO GO
AWAY, BUT AT 5:05 THIS EVENING
IS WHEN YOU FIND OUT, OH,
ACTUALLY YOU HAVE ANOTHER ANGLE
TO THE STORY.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
TOMORROW CAN BE SURE THAT THESE
QUESTIONS WILL CONTINUE.
SHE'LL HAVE TO GO UP ONE SIDE
AND THEN THE OTHER AND WON'T
COMMENT.
MIKE McCURRY DURING THE
LEWINSKY SCANDAL HAD A GREAT
LINE, "I'M DOUBLE-PARKED IN THE
NO COMMENT ZONE."
NOBODY IS LAUGHING TODAY.
THEY FEEL THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN THE
RUN-AROUND.
MAYBE SHE DOESN'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE -- AT WHAT
WON'T DID THEY INFORM HER?
IS SHE PLAYING CATCH-UP?
YOU HAVE TO ACT ALMOST AS A
LAWYER WHEN YOU'RE THE PRESS
SECRETARY TO SAY, OKAY, YOU'RE
TELLING ME THIS IS TRUE NOW, BUT
NONE OF THIS MAKES SENSE.
SO WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO TELL ME
TOMORROW THAT'S DIFFERENT?
YOU HAVE TO THINK AHEAD TO THREE
OR FOUR DAYS.
>> Jeanine: AND DON'T MAKE ME
LOOK LIKE A FUEL LIKE I DON'T
KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT,
BECAUSE THEY ALREADY KNOW BASED
ON TOMORROW THEY'LL KNOW I
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN.
>> Brian: GREG, YOU'VE BEEN
HEARING PEOPLE GOING BACK AND
FORTH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT, SO THE PRESSURE IS ON YOU
TO SAY SOMETHING WE DON'T
EXPECT.
>> Greg: THAT'S A CHALLENGE,
BRIAN.
BY THE WAY, GREAT TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
>> Brian: DO YOU REALLY MEAN
THAT?
>> Greg: NO.
WHO IS HE?
THERE'S AN ARGUMENT THAT SAYS,
OH, THIS IS NOTHING.
IT MIGHT BE NOTHING, BUT THAT
ISN'T THE POINT.
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT, HOW DO YOU
PREVENT THE FUTURE HYSTERIA THAT
WE SAW WHEN THE MEDIA UNLEASHED
THIS INSANE AMOUNT OF PRESS
ABOUT MAR-A-LAGO OR ABOUT
TRUMP'S TAXES OR ABOUT THE
DOSSIER?
AND I ALWAYS SAY, I DO THE
ARGUMENT, WE SHOULD BE BETTER
THAN THAT WHEN IT HAPPENS, YOU
KNOW, WE'LL BE THE BETTER
PERSON.
THAT DOESN'T WORK.
BEING THE BETTER PERSON DOESN'T
WORK.
YOU HAVE TO RETURN IT IN SPADES.
SO THAT WAY THEY LEARN A LESSON
THE NEXT TIME THEY'RE ABOUT TO
DO SOMETHING IN WHICH THEY GO
CRAZY ABOUT SOMETHING THAT'S NOT
THERE, SAYING IT'S WORSE THAN
WATERGATE AND SO ON.
THEY'LL REMEMBER, WELL, YOU
KNOW, THE REPUBLICANS CAN DO THE
SAME THING.
IT GOES BACK TO, WHO KNEW THIS
STUFF EXISTED AND WHEN, AND DID
THEY HOLD IT BACK TO INFLUENCE
AN ELECTION?
WAIT.
LET ME FINISH, MR. KILMEADE.
>> Brian: GO AHEAD.
>> Greg: DO THEY HOLD IT BACK TO
INFLUENCE THIS ELECTION?
BECAUSE THERE'S PRECEDENCE FOR
THAT.
AND SUCH PRECEDENCE ONLY GOES IN
ONE DIRECTION, JUST LIKE THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" THING.
IT ONLY GOES IN ONE DIRECTION.
SO IT IS NOT ABOUT, SAY, THE
OBJECTIVE, PROTECTING THE
ELECTION FROM LATE BREAKING FAKE
NEWS.
THAT'S THE HONORABLE THING TO
DO, RIGHT?
LIKE WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE THE
STORY AFFECT THE NEWS, AND IT
TURNS OUT TO BE FAKE.
THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO MIND THE
"ACCESS HOLLYWOOD" TAPE.
AGAIN, THEIR INTERFERENCE ONLY
GOES IN ONE DIRECTION.
IF THEY TRIED TO STOP OR KILL
THE "ACCESS HOLLYWOOD" TAPE,
THAT WOULD BE DIFFERENT, BUT
AMAZING HOW THE PRESS DROPPED
THAT AT EXACTLY THE RIGHT TIME.
STILL DIDN'T WORK.
>> Brian: WE TALK ABOUT
DOCUMENTS BEING CLASSIFIED AT
THE HIGHEST LEVEL.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF WHAT'S IN
THOSE DOCUMENTS IS THE REAL
STORY?
THE FACT THEY EXIST IN THE WRONG
PLACE IS THE STORY.
BUT WHAT IF HE REVEAL UKRAINE
AND --
>> Jeanine: HUNTER BIDEN.
>> Brian: WE'LL SEE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY THEY SAID,
WHATEVER YOU DO, DON'T TELL JOE
WHAT THEY FOUND, WHEN HE ASKED I
DON'T WANT TO ASK WHAT THEY
FOUND IN MY GARAGE.
>> Jeanine: OR WHY IT TOOK TWO
MONTHS FROM THE TIME THEY FOUND
THEM --
>> Dana: ALSO, YOU'RE THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF, AND SHOULD
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> Jeanine: DOESN'T THAT DEMAND
AN EARLY MORNING ATTACK, BECAUSE
IT IN YOUR HOUSE.
>> Geraldo: SAME QUESTION OVER
AND OV